네. 안녕하세요. 빌사남입니다.
오늘은 중계일을 하면서 재미난
에피소드를 좀 소개해 드리려고 하는데
오늘 저희 회사에 약간 유머를
담당하고 있는 정성문 이사님
모셨습니다. 아주 부동산 중계 하고
있어요. 빌딩 중계. 형님 예전에
한번 보긴 봤었네. 저 친구 결혼식
때 아 진짜로? 사 오셔가지고 아
진짜로? 저 보고 잘생겼다고 그때.
아 그런 얘기 저보고 잘생겼다고
그때.
아 그런 얘기. 실수를 했네. 가
고양은
빌사남의 노크
안녕하세요. 저는 필산남 부동산
중개범인이 일하고 있는 정성훈
이사라고 합니다.네 반갑습니다. 되게
재미난 에피소드가 있어서 아 이거
촬영하면 좋을 것 같다라고 해가지고
어 이렇게 좀 촬영을 하게 됐습니다.
어떤 에피소드였나요? 거기 김밥집
사장님이셨는데 아 김밥집 건물을
가지고 계신 연세 많으신 분이셨는데
퇴직하시고 이제는 이제 고향으로
가시려고 건물 정리하고 가시려고
했는데 근데 그분께서 제가 결혼하기
전이었었는데 한참 오래 전이긴 한데
저를 좀 좋게 봐 주셨는지 어 자기가
다니는 카페에 참한 처자가 있는데 어
아 카페 처자네 카페 일하시는 분이
있는데 그분을 한번 만나봤으면
좋겠다라고 계속 말씀을 하셔 가지고
그래서 일단은 만나기로 해서 제다이를
말씀드리고 아 그러면 네 살 차이다.
아, 그런 궁합도 안 본다. 그래서
그냥 아무 정보도 없이 마포 합중동
쪽에서 만났었거든요. 근데 만났는데
저거네 살이 많은 거예요.
뭐 저의 느낌상으로네 살이 어릴 어릴
거라고 생각했었는데 아, 더
많았구나.네 네 살이 많은 신이
나오셔 가지고 되게 깜짝 좀
놀랐었거든요. 그 당시에 제가 그때
뭐 투사에 예전에 영감한 기자들로
나가고 그것이 알고 싶대서 나갔던
그런 사진들을 넣어 놨었었거든요.
근데 그분이 그걸 보시고 음 제가
연인이라고 생각을 하시고 아 기대를
많이 했고
기대 아 기대 아 기대도 많이 하고
아 그렇지 그 기대를 많이하고
만 아니 저도 기대를 많이 뭐
기대했다기보다는데 사실은 그분도네 살
차이라고 해서 나이가 많은 사람이
나올 거라고 생각했었고 저는 나이가
얼릴 거라고 생각했었는데 나이가 많은
사람이 나왔고 5분인가 10분 정도만
있고 바로 헤어졌어요. 그러니까 첫
인상이 어땠지? 아 천인상 아 천인상
너무 좋아지 천인상 천인상 너무 좋
너무 좋았다고 뭐 어떤 아 너무 어떤
스타일이 아 너무 예쁘시고 이게
진동체를 다가 주신 분들이 생각이
드는데 나이가 많이 들어보셨어요?
이거 이건 약간 놀란될 거 같아.
저희 눈에는 너무 누나 같았었고 조금
그 자리도 사실은 첫만남이어서 좀
불편하기도 했었는데 상대방이 먼저 뭐
가시려고 해서 어 그럼 뭐 식사라도
이렇게 말을 던졌는데 당연히 아니라고
이야기하셔 가지고 제가 당연히
아니라고 하시더라고. 저 5분 10분
앉아 있고 바로 헤어졌거든요. 아
그래서 조금 힘들었습니다. 이게 좀
예. 그 저도 예. 예전에 저기 그
건물집은 사모님이셨는데 미팅하자
그래서 저도 이제 만나러 갔는데
갑자기 이제 나이랑 막 물어보시더
그때 제가 20대 중반이었나 나이를
많이 물어보세요 맞아 맞아 그래서
잠깐 있어 보라고 그때 갑자기
전화하시더니
딸을 데고 온 거 아 딸을 데리고
없어요 이거 딸을 왜 데고 온 거죠
아 이게 소개팅 시켜준 아 소개팅
시켜 준다 아 예나요 그 딸이
은행당에 아 은행당이셨 뭐 나이들
비슷했거든 아 예 왔는지
네. 예지 녹으면 와이프 혼나요? 아
결혼하기 전이라서 그죠. 결혼하기
전이 오래 전이었으니까 몇 번지
얘기도 갑자기 이제 딸분이 오시더니
갑자기 이제 그 사모님이 나 어 나
급한 일 있어 갑자기 가시더 아
그분은 그럼 나이는 어떻 어떻게
했었어요?
혹시 많으셨나요? 아니 저보다
어렸어. 어렸어요. 아 동갑이었나?
근데 그분도 뭐 잠깐 얘기하다가
마음에 안 드셨는지 따로 연락은 하진
않아. 아, 전화번호 받으셨나요?
전화번호는 받았던 거 같아. 아,
받았어요. 아, 알겠습니다. 은행
다니셨던 아직도 기억이 났는데. 근데
그 사모님이 되게 자산이 많으니시.
아, 자산. 그러니까 저도 그얘기
묻고 싶긴 했었는데. 아, 그럼 지금
뭐 후회하시는 건가요? 아니, 아니,
전혀 뭐 그렇지 않지. 아, 그런 건
아닌 거요. 다른 에피소님 또 뭐가
있어요? 다른 에피소드도 이거
하나밖에 없는데요.
지금 머릿속에 아무것도 거의 세
개구가 하지 않어.
사투이랑 영어 이탈리어 아 그죠 그죠
영어 이탈리어 그렇게 안 보이지만
이제 국걸하시고
아 이제 재밌는 이야기 생각났어요
진짜 뭐 저희 여사 지금 청남동에
있으니까 지금은 PH1로 바뀌었지만
예전에 저기 LOE가 있었지 않을까
저녁 놀고 나서 새벽집에 간 적이
있었는데 주문하려고 뭐 사장님 이렇게
불렀겠죠. 육회 비빔밥이랑 뭐 이렇게
회장국이랑 시켰던 거 같아요. 그래서
시켰는데 그 저원 분께서 저를 많이
쳐다보시더니만 왜 영화 하시는데
사투리로
주문하시 당황스럽어. 왜냐하면 저는
서울 때가 아니어 가지고 그 영어를
잘 쓰면이 사람도서울 서울말을 써야
되는 그 평견에 있었어 가지고 그럼
여기서 도전 한번
할까요?서 얼지 요거 이제 서울말로
한번 읽어 보세요. 아 서울말로요?
서울발로 서울발로게요. 행복 같은데.
서울발로 한번 해 보겠습니다.
[음악]
안녕하세요라고 해야 되는데. 아,
괜찮네. 안녕하세요.
아, 그렇죠. 안녕하세 안녕하세요.
필사람입니다. 이렇게 돼야 될 것
같은데. 아, 이거 이상한 거
같은데. 이상하죠? 이상합니다. 진짜
제가 봐.
이상해 사실 정체성이 조금 혼란데
있긴 해. 그니까 서울에 오면 인테리
한번 보여줄 수 있네. 뭐 이렇게
해야 돼요. 제 이름은
정성문입니다라고 이야기하면 미끼야 뭐
선거문드 정그 이렇게 들어가거든. 정
예예. 차오. 예. 보나 보나
보나세라. 어 약간 이상한 거
아니에. 아니 그 그렇게 하는 거야
그게. 아 그게 정상적인 말인 거야.
아, 그게 진짜 그렇게 하는 거예요.
그래서 크리스티나 말투가 그런
거예요. 아. 예. 그니까 뭐 제가
뭐 아이로 뭐 제가 아침 8시에
일어났습니다. 이렇게 하면 미스벨류
알레오 이렇게 들어가 아 진짜 이렇게
들어가요. 그게 그게 정상적인 말이고
검증을 한번 해봐야겠네 이게. 아,
근데 제 아, 제가 아, 검증하면
되죠, 뭐. 뭐 검증하도록
하겠습니다. 뭐. 네. 그래서 오늘
그 정성문 이사님이랑 되게 재미난
에피소드 좀 몇 개 얘기했고 사실
사투리를 쓰긴 하지만 서울에 좀
10년 이상 사신 분이고 거기다 이제
영어는 너무 잘하고 거기다 이제
이태리어까지 세계 국어를 하시는
정성문 이사님 오시고 좀 촬영을
했고요. 그래서 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하고요. 다음 시간에 뵙도록
하겠습니다.
감사합니다. 안녕.
[음악]